um give me if you're on an island
stranded for 365 days you can only bring
Five albums with you on an iPod now stop
it first of all an iPod you're not gonna
have Wi-Fi because you're going to be on
an island use your phone well my iPod
die though I don't know right okay
keep it keep it because they're going to
be sewage well I'm definitely taking the
age of pleasure okay because I know that
we made that project to be on an island
to be on an island to transport me I
need a soundtrack to that okay I have to
take some prints so maybe I'll take
Purple Rain all right I gotta take some
Stevie shout out to Stevie intervisions
or music of my mind
some Harold Bud he has an album it puts
me in a super meditative space one more
oh God this is tough
um what about a hip give me a hip-hop
one oh okay
um maybe I take the love below okay
speaker box